today joe biden will be announcing
multiple executive actions on guns
on firearm safety it may already have
happened by the time you listen to
today's show or watch today's clips
this is already angering many people
but it has to happen because we have a
gun violence crisis in this country we
have a gun culture crisis in this
country
one of the actions joe biden is expected
to take
is to deal with what are called ghost
guns guns without serial numbers
sometimes which can be made at home
biden is expected to direct the
administration to start a process that
will require
buyers of so-called ghost guns to
undergo
background checks a question remains
about
exactly what joe biden is going to do
and again
by by now meaning when you're listening
to today's show
we may already know biden previously
called on the senate to pass stricter
background check rules
the house has already passed them these
would make background checks apply to
every gun sale and transfer
it would give the fbi more time to
conduct background checks
whether something related to that will
be part of the orders
we we just don't know yet a joe biden
might announce some regulations
on concealed and or assault style
firearms maybe prohibitions on firearm
purchases for those
convicted of domestic violence against
partners maybe something about
alerting law enforcement agencies when
potential buyers
fail background checks that these are
people you may want to keep an eye on as
they may try to obtain a firearm some
other way
potentially federal guidance on home
storage safety
measures there's a whole bunch of
possibilities and we'll know them very
soon if we don't already
but what we can be absolutely certain of
is that a huge portion of the american
right wing
will be against whatever joe biden
announces
they will say all the things that they
always say and to prepare you for that
we need to not lose sight of the big
picture whatever joe biden announces or
announced
today changes nothing about the second
amendment we have a second amendment
people have a right to own firearms none
of joe biden's orders will
change that joe biden essentially has no
choice
but to do this and why think back
to the sandy hook shooting when
democrats had
the white house under barack obama the
house of representatives
the senate and nearly 90 percent of
americans
supported a law for universal
background checks such a milk toast
thing such a basic thing
democrats still couldn't get it done
because of opposition
from republicans because of opposition
from the gun lobby
if you can't get universal background
checks done
in that environment after one of the
worst school shootings in american
history
controlling the white house house and
senate and having the american public on
your side at an 88 to 90 percent
level which is almost unheard of in the
hyper partisan american political status
quo
i don't know that you can ever really
get anything done unless a president
just says
i'm doing executive action so this has
to happen
they will say biden is coming for your
guns they will say biden is ending the
second amendment none of it is true
but let's see what joe biden does
or did if it already happened depending
on when you listen to today's show
and then we will talk more about the
implications of what he does what he
does but
it has to be done there's no other
choice you know you hear from the right
some on the right say well we should
work together the
the left the democratic party shouldn't
uh act unilaterally
what choice do they have when 90
of the country wants background checks
and republicans still don't so
once we know exactly what joe biden
signs we will
have more on this on the david pakman
show instagram page
make sure you are following us there at
david pakman show
on instagram one of our sponsors purevpn
is giving you 47 off a one-year plan
which comes out to less than
six bucks a month purevpn makes you
anonymous online
and you can trust them they're the only
vpn with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country purevpn is super fast
with over
6500 servers and you can use it on all
of your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman